all right i love this next story
republican senator lindsey graham has
now been caught on audio recordings from
a little while ago
slamming trump and saying joe biden's
actually good joe biden is the best
person in this post
riot moment that the united states faced
over a year ago this you have to listen
to this stuff to believe it so let's get
right into it new audio tapes have
leaked of senator lindsey graham saying
trump went too far and plays the tv game
while calling biden the best person to
have post january 6th now these are
reasonable comments it's it's yes trump
has gone too far trump plays the tv game
joe biden was at least a good person to
have in that he brings calm and
rationality and and sort of the the
opposite of the mania of much of the
right
um but the reason it's notable is that
lindsey graham is a republican senator
and publicly he was praising trump and
saying trump's grade and all these
different things with occasional moments
of disagreeing with donald trump a new
audio has leaked of senator lindsey
graham revealing his feelings about
biden and trump graham is heard saying
he thinks biden is the best person to
have after the capital riot graham also
criticizes trump in another tape saying
he plays the tv game and went too far so
let's get to uh some of this um some of
these clips some of this audio take a
listen
we'll actually come out of this thing
moments like this reset
it'll take a while
people have calmed down
people
i don't want to be associated with that
so this is from the book this will not
pass by jonathan martin and alex burns
this is where a lot of these leaked
recordings of kevin mccarthy criticizing
trump and others have come from and the
picture that we're increasingly uh
having painted for us
is of prominent republicans
who publicly were 98
or 99 or 100
behind trump but privately
knew how bad he was and we're actually
saying so sometimes let's continue this
is a group within a group
and what this does is there'll be a
rallying effect for a while for the
country says we're better than this now
what's fascinating about that before we
get to now he's going to praise joe
biden
lindsey graham and kevin mccarthy and
others
they thought they were expecting in the
immediate aftermath of the trump riots
they were expecting that everybody
including the republican trump base
would say
this is too far
this was wrong this was trumpists trump
incited it everybody sees what happened
and they would denounce it
but then
internal polling started to say
otherwise internal polling started to
say actually people have fought
republicans have fallen for biden stole
the election
some of them fell for it was antifa
slash black lives matter slash the fbi
who did the riots
they fell for it and then we very
quickly realized that the private
expectations of people like lindsey
graham and kevin mccarthy that the
country is not going to stand for this
we can step away from trump because
everybody's going to they were wrong
and then they had to backtrack here is
lindsey graham talking about
biden being a good person to actually
have uh at this point in time trying to
get the shot right for everybody here so
we can see this okay here we go
totally he'll be uh
maybe the best person to have right
i mean
how bad can you get it go by
graham says
joe biden is maybe the best person to
have
in the aftermath of the trump riots
wow
wow
so if you compare january 6 lindsey
graham to the lindsey graham of today
how stark are the differences because we
should point out
that lindsey graham went publicly said
that he had you know he he hated the way
it ended with him and trump but he'd had
enough
yeah
you can almost hear in his voice
anderson senator graham trying to sort
of play out what the impact of this
attack which as we talked was was still
sort of ongoing as we spoke so there is
lindsey graham saying trump's a pretty
good person for this let me see if we
can get there was one more clip i was
hoping to play
um
i guess i don't have it okay which is
fine but i believe we have the
tren oh okay i have a transcript of the
second tape in a second tape graham
criticizes trump's rhetoric prior to the
riot
he was accused of inciting quote he
plays the tv game and he went too far
here that rally didn't help talking
about primary liz cheney he created a
sense of revenge he created a sense of
revenge so i've said this before and i'm
going to restate it
i believe that
this is worse than being a true believer
the true believers who really support
trump
they're at least
their only wrong
and their moral compass is misguided and
we can make a lot of criticisms of the
true believers of trump the false
believers i believe are even worse
because on top of all of the bad things
that they are supporting by publicly
supporting donald trump
they are knowingly
allowing their country to be damaged for
purposes of political expediency or
maintaining access to the office of the
presidency or maintaining a favorable
relationship with their constituents or
whatever the case may be i think that
the false believers are worse from a
moral standpoint and we can put mitch
mcconnell in this as well to some degree
i mean in the immediate aftermath of the
trump riots mitch mcconnell clearly
expected to some degree
that the vast majority of the republican
base would dump trump but mitch
mcconnell was part of the republicans
who also thought the republican base
would never choose trump as their
nominee back in 2015 and 2016. so
he's been wrong time and time again he's
been wrong every time about
now they're going to abandon and so they
end up having to kind of backtrack and
for someone i mean listen mitch
mcconnell graham they're not political
idiots to some they're a little bit
astute when it comes to politics in some
sense
they all seem
unable to realize
how
monstrously unaffected of a significant
portion of the trump base is by the
things that actually take place go all
the way back to grab them by the you
know what and that tape it almost seems
quaint and naive in some weird way to
think back to when we thought wow
trump's primary candidacy it's got to be
over right i mean grab them by the
you-know-what you can just do what you
want and all these allegations
it didn't matter anymore it didn't
matter and uh
it is a monstrous base and if we've
learned one thing it's that if you
overestimate the morality and
intelligence of the trump base you end
up being wrong you end up disappointed
or in places you don't necessarily
expect to be and that's what happened to
lindsey graham it's what happened to
kevin mccarthy it's what happened to
mitch mcconnell they expected at some
point their base would wake up to the
madman that was trump and they never did
and these are their constituents
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card
privacy will autofill a virtual card
number and then after signing up i can
delete that virtual card so i know i'm
not going to be charged again something
really useful and very practical or
let's say i'm ordering food over the
phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video